Chris Pratt you like getting naked I've
spent a good amount of time naked yeah
but it has got you in trouble in your in
your sitcom yes yeah this is Parks and
Recreation the sitcom I played this guy
who is is dim-witted and guileless but a
a real idiot but he he got kicked out of
his girlfriend's house anyways long
story short she has invited him to come
back to the house for some reason but I
think it's to hook up so I come back
naked now I open I knock on the door and
Amy polar's character opens the door and
says Andy and I'm naked and that's the
bit to me it didn't seem like she really
was reacting to seeing my dick
I know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna drop
my trial as an improv I ran it by the
boom mic operator I was like dude should
I get naked he was like
he opens the door and she goes Andy
and then I got a letter from NBC saying
basically it can't happen again and also
we don't want you going around and
talking about this letter like it was
something some kind of joke